how's your son amazing super cute the
most of Dorian baby cute but he's like
rightful of that what they were the
cutest yeah I think they're cuter than
bunnies and puppies combined and I
personally I would throw away 20 white
babies to have an Asian baby but good
news you'd throw them away I would throw
them away but the exchange rate is
better than that now so it's six to one
because the economy is very strong yeah
so yeah he's adorable and you know he's
saying words and I'm he's like a 3/4
white my I'm half Peruvian so so we've
been teaching him Spanish because it's
part of his heritage and I speak Spanish
and you know there's also utility and
knowing Spanish so many people speak
horse yeah and then my wife's Hungarian
which is fine and she she's like I
wanted to be proud of Hungarian roots
okay
and she goes I want him to speak
Hungarian I'm like why it's like so he
can be an arms dealer or something so
like okay she goes well you need to help
and I go yeah I don't speak Hungarian
so she's teaching me elementary
Hungarian and then I have to remember it
so I'm teaching him like like named Egon
rohad Tegan which is like yes no rotten
gypsy like all the things that she's
that she's teaching you so that you can
teach him yeah that's because like
whoever's with him like make sure you
enforce that and then like little
Hungarian songs that I guess she learned
in like oh if you want to try one of the
water okay so this is the one that I've
been this is a real Hungarian song the
real earlier in song that my wife used
to sing as a kid and now we're teaching
our son okay so it goes as sheikah ho
Yashica ho Pengy Carlo
Pengy Kahlo Sarika quiche Soroka quiche
Chico Chico that was great beautiful
what is that
that that means it's snowing outside all
the horses are farting and the littlest
horse is taking a [ __ ] is that really
what that me really what that what is
that a song I mean I've been married to
her for you they're different yeah it's
just different people
you